i've found over the years that quite a
few people have
questions or confusions about my
academic career
and that's perfectly understandable
since i have held
more than 10 positions over the last you
know 20 odd years
of various teaching
and research and other things and i've
done so not just in academic areas but
also with educational startups so if
you've you know if you've followed me in
the last 10 years you've probably seen
quite a few
changes and you might be wondering
what's going on so i'm going to give a
entire
back history
of where i've taught what i was teaching
how things were going why i moved from
that position to the other because it
might be of interest to some
and i even i think for quite a few
people who know me well there's gonna be
as it turns out gaps in what they
actually knew about where i was and so
this could be helpful in a number of
ways or at the least maybe interesting
and entertaining
so let me start by saying
where i
currently teach and what position i hold
so i teach at milwaukee institute of art
and design just about a mile from where
i'm shooting this video
and i'll say this too it's the best
place that i've ever taught and so you
know that says a lot given how many
places i've actually been to and seen
from the inside and i hold the it might
be oxymoronic rank
of adjunct professor
so you might say well how can you be
both an adjunct and a professor
my ad has tracks not just for professors
going from assistant to associate to
full professor
they also have tracks for adjuncts and
you get you know pay raises along the
way
and you know a certain rank and i came
in as a adjunct full professor because
of my many years of teaching experience
and
publications and service work and stuff
like that so i can't actually proceed
any further but it goes adjunct lecturer
and then you have to apply for you know
an increase to adjunct assistant
professor adjunct associate professor
adjunct full professor so that's how how
that works and adjunct and myad is its
own
kind of different universe because it is
a school of art and design a
professional school that you know grants
college degrees but it's primarily
geared towards artists and designers and
so people like me
were teaching in the humanities and
writing program and and you could say
helping them out along the way to become
well-rounded practitioners now since
we're we've got the present let's go all
the way back in time to
the distant past and i'm going to break
this up into a bunch of different
sections so the first thing to talk
about is where i went to graduate school
at southern illinois
university and where i taught while i
was down there
one of the really great things about the
philosophy program at southern illinois
university and i think this was you know
similar to the other
programs in other graduate departments
there which was kind of a powerhouse for
a while
was that if you wanted to there were
many ways to get lots of teaching
experience and
that's part of what i did now the first
three years that i was there i didn't
teach at all because i had won a
fellowship the delete morris fellowship
and that gave me
you know free tuition a stipend i still
had to pay you know fees and stuff but
it was enough to live on for me
and then after that finished
i began ta-ing that's being a teaching
assistant
uh various professors and i i did that
for a logic class with george shetler
and i did that for an intro to
philosophy class with my mentor garth
gillen and um you know being a ta meant
you were sort of like a teacher light
right uh there'd be a big lecture
section with 200 to 300 students in it
and then you would have your breakout
sessions usually on like fridays or
thursdays later in the week and you
would teach
that little 20 to 25 person section but
you're teaching what the teacher was
teaching right
and so i did that for logic and then you
know intro to philosophy but intro to
philosophy is a little bit different
because
garth wanted us to get teaching
experience so he built it into the
syllabus that two of the lectures
in the course of the semester would be
given by each ta so
you had to present to this massive
auditorium what he was doing so i did
that and then
after a while
they would trust you with your own class
and they began by giving me
sections of ethics to teach and you'd
have to pick out your textbook and
arrange your syllabus
and figure out how you were going to do
assignments you'd have a little bit of
guidance if you asked for it but
otherwise you're kind of just thrown
into it and i taught ethics twice
beginning
in 1999
and then um
i was slated to teach a higher level
class called philosophy of politics law
and justice and i thought that was so
cool
around that time my my mother died and i
began having to go up to milwaukee to
handle her
funeral and arrangements and estate and
house and all that sort of stuff and
then come back so
that class i actually had a few of my my
you know fellow classmates take over
sections but i saw it through to the end
and then i didn't teach for a little
while because i got a dissertation
research award to work on things but i
already had three
of my own classes under my belt at that
time
my last semester there
um i
was kind of fortunate in that i'd run
out of funding by that time
so i i had the inheritance that i could
draw upon that and i began teaching
for
southeastern illinois college which was
about maybe 45 minutes down the road
from carbondale going due east i forget
which town it's in but it's a community
college and so
uh i i knew one of my my friends who was
in the english department his wife was a
professor there and she was like hey we
need somebody to teach philosophy
classes do you think you want to do it
and i was like yeah sounds good so i
would ride in with with her we arranged
our schedules so they worked out well
i think
maybe not every day but but most days
and
then i would teach
twice a week
introduction to philosophy
ethics
and world religions and this is great
because it was giving me
more
staple classes that you need and i only
did that for a semester i you know
finished my dissertation graduated
and then we moved to northwestern
indiana and that's where the the second
part of the story begins
my family has had land in northwestern
indiana near
demotte and rose lawn
off of highway 10 since the 1930s and
there's a lot to say about that maybe
i'll talk about that somewhere else it's
a quite interesting story suffice it to
say there's a you could call it a
compound shalem reeves right the the
lamry's place and there's three houses
there that my grandparents and
great aunts and great
uncles built as retirement homes
and by the time that i was finishing up
graduate school my grandmother and
grandpa were still alive my aunt tony
was still alive but she was suffering
from alzheimer's
and had basically moved out of her house
in with my aunt bibian
who was a nurse and they were they were
essentially taking care of her my
grandfather was also suffering from
alzheimer's and eventually had to be put
in a retirement home but um
you know
at that time i was heavily involved my
family
this is my mother's side of the family
and by that time i was also married i
had
my oldest daughter you know she was born
in 2002 and so by the time i'm
graduating i'm a family man and i have
to think about where i'm going to go so
what often happens with academics is
they say well i'll go wherever the jobs
are and i thought about that and i was
like
i really want to be where my family is
i've got these connections throughout my
life to this land wouldn't it be nice to
move in there so i used what was left of
my inheritance to buy
one of the houses and we moved in and
then the question was okay what am i
going to do for work
so i sent out
cover letters and cvs to
every
college university that offered
philosophy classes within what i thought
to be
a
two-hour driving radius
and i was like well we'll see what
happens and i got some some responses
right away
nor uh
indiana university
northwest based up in gary asked me if i
could teach a professional ethics class
for them which was actually at a high
school because part of continuing
education rather than on the main campus
manchester college way out
in
eastern
indiana about two hours drive booked me
in to teach two ethics classes and so i
was like well
looks like the this will be
more or less it for the time being i did
interview
for lewis university now that i recall
and they wanted people to teach like in
the the chicagoland area
so that was a possibility and then i got
a call from ball state university and it
was from the the chair of the philosophy
and religious studies department julie
eflin and she said hey um
this is a little bit unusual
but do you think you would be interested
in teaching up in michigan city
at indiana state prison we have a
four-year
degree program prison education the
prisoners don't get a philosophy degree
but they can minor in philosophy or
religious studies which by the way you
have to teach both of those and they get
a degree in general studies and you know
the guy who was working up at indiana
state prison he's leaving all of a
sudden do you think you'd want to
take his place and i was like
what's what's the deal well you'll be an
assistant professor you're you're a
member of the department
and this will be like your full-time gig
and i thought about it and i was like
how many classes am i going to teach he
said well
he's slated for five
and i was like wow i've already got
three classes elsewhere and
the five is this doable and i was like
well maybe for a semester it is i'll
i'll try it out right
so that was a very intense semester i
stepped into the classes that he
had scheduled which included religion in
american life intro to philosophy
world religions
jesus and the gospel traditions which
was an upper level class and then there
was there was another maybe there were
two sections of of religion in american
culture so i had a lot of preps a lot of
different things to do
and
after that semester i didn't teach for
indiana university northwest anymore or
for manchester college
i just taught for ball state in their
prison program and i will say this it
was very
tough but very rewarding i mean
physically you know the place was filled
with mold so my allergies were killing
me i had to get uh inserts for my my
shoes because walking on concrete all
the time was kind of rough
you were constantly having to shout
above hvac and fans and stuff like that
my vocal cords would get so strained by
the way the classes were all
uh anywhere from two to three hours
depending on the prison schedule
once a week and so like mondays i would
teach three classes with a break in
between and i could be teaching anywhere
from you know seven to nine hours where
i'm talking the entire time so i would
you know bring in ricola and and sip hot
tea and stuff like that and it was it
was great you know it it gave me an
academic position i was full-time i
unfortunately as i found out later
i was not eligible
because i was in extended education for
tenure or promotion because my chair
told me look at all these publications
you've got we would be promoting you to
associate professor but my hands are
tight but it was a job and i really
enjoyed you know talking with the
students and the the
freedom to teach the things that i
wanted to to teach
gave me a huge vast background
in teaching a whole bunch of philosophy
classes and religious studies classes
and it lasted for six years
unfortunately
um the state of indiana in 2008
very suddenly decided to
make the prisoners ineligible for the
low-income student grant that they were
getting it was always rather unpopular
politically although it was a you know
prison education is is very good for
reducing the recidivism rate the rate of
people going back to
prison committing further crimes
it's one of the most cost-effective
measures we actually have but indiana is
you know a red state and they were
against that that sort of thing so they
finally got rid of it so i had to get on
the job market
very very late i had been interviewing
for other jobs along the way while i was
at indiana
state prison teaching there you know i
had a
catholic studies job up at university
illinois of chicago that i was in the
running for i got to the top four
interviewed didn't get it i went out to
steubenville
interviewed there there were other
interviews as well but i i didn't get
them
and so um
in late to
2007 i had to get on the job market
a little bit behind everybody else and
that's how i wound up in the
the second
academic
position
that i would take down in north carolina
the way people now get hired in the
academic job market is a bit different
than the way it used to be back then you
know sometimes
back then you could have a skype
interview although that was pretty much
a rarity and it depended how tech savvy
the department was generally you had to
go to the american philosophical
association which was in between
christmas and new year's terrible time
of the year
and do your initial interviews there
with all the other people
in you know like a giant room
and the people doing the interviews that
have to do like you know anywhere from
10 to 18 interviews over a couple days
and then it would go to the next thing
you'd wait for like an email or a phone
call you know we'd like to do a
follow-up can you come to campus to do
an interview and that sort of thing
and i i had a couple um interviews at
the apa including with ball state
one of the professors was actually
pretty hostile to the writing sample
that i'd submitted
kind of a jerk actually
didn't go any further with that
i
did get an interview with saint anselm's
college where i was giving the saint
anselm lecture
that year so they kind of rolled those
in together and the people that are
really into anselm were really into me
and i think a lot of the other people
were not the department was in a
considerable flux
i did get two
job offers and
one was locally it was at a place that
if i remember correctly was
in or near joliet so about 45 minutes
drive and it was a community college
and i was going to be you know teaching
philosophy and religious studies classes
um and it's interesting because that
would have been a union position
and like guaranteed pay raises and stuff
like that so this is 2008 remember that
that date the other was at fayetteville
state university in north carolina
and it was for a mixed department
called government and history which
included some philosophy people but it
didn't have a philosophy major
and basically what you were doing is
teaching critical thinking classes but
you know they offered more money uh it
was a university so the you know the
worry was
and this is a well-founded worry if i
went to that community college
it might be very difficult to ever get
out of there and get another position
again because you know a lot of hiring
is based not just on where you went to
going to southern illinois university as
opposed to going to university of
chicago it puts you at a disadvantage
publications even those things outside
lots of publications
um but where you're currently teaching
can also be viewed as you know a feather
in the cap or as a mark against you
so i thought well we'll i'll i'll do
this i'll go to southern i'll go down to
the south to north carolina take up this
position here at this historically black
university
and it'll be going like like going on
military deployment i'll leave my family
up there in indiana on you know the
family land and i will you know come
back for breaks and you know whenever i
can and i'll live in a little apartment
down there and you know do my job and
then you know plan to like you know
spend the whole summer
because who the hell wants to spend the
summer
in a place as hot as as a
fayetteville go back up to indiana now
what ended up happening were a couple
real
interconnected let's call them
challenges or catastrophes first of all
the economy melted down right 2008. so i
went down there and by the way
fayetteville state university
totally dysfunctional at the time they
were in the process of firing the
chancellor and replacing her with a new
chancellor who was also not very good
and kind of a stuffed shirt type his
chief of staff was extraordinary and he
actually like ran the place but it was
it was there was so much wrong with the
institution we didn't have contracts
when we got down there
we didn't have offices and yet we were
required to hold office hours and every
time you'd ask a question they the
people would be like well you just gotta
understand the institutional culture
down here it's a little bit different
than you know what you're used to up
north and and you know i would just get
infuriated right so there's all of that
stuff
and
um i also wound up uh first getting
separated and then getting divorced um
you know things broke down and uh
in order to actually be able to
get to see my kids i had to start
divorce proceedings and so
there was all of that going on and i
would go on the job market while i was
at fayetteville state university i
didn't really want to stay there
although i got really wrapped up in a
lot of things because you know they they
found i found out i was good at certain
things they found out i was good at it
and so they would detail me i wound up
in the academic senate i started a
ethics and business education project
with the the school of business and
economics that you know helped them uh
get you know
get through their uh re-accreditation i
got involved in the entire
reaccreditation thing and helped write
the 10-year quality enhancement plan uh
one entire chapter is is what i wrote
and i had a part in the others i
defended the the plan to uh sacks which
is the uh the reaccreditors i
was involved in and then ran
university-wide
assessment of student learning so i was
you know i was getting pretty uh well
positioned there but something else
happened that changed their trajectory
of where i was going
entirely
and led to me moving somewhere else
the next stop for me was to move up to
new york and into the hudson valley
specifically to kingston which is on the
west side of the the river
and i started teaching for a place on
the east side of the river called marist
college and i started teaching as an
adjunct now why would i leave
a position where i had job security i
was involved in all these different
things i was actually up for
early tenure and early promotion if i
had
stayed well because i fell in love and
it was with somebody who i knew from
high school i think many of you know
this story andy shaka and i went to
catholic memorial high school together
uh we met when when i was a sophomore
and she was a freshman she actually
dated a guy who was at that time my
archrival
and then you know we we lose track of
each other we cross paths again living
here in milwaukee in the 1990s both of
us working at a building just blocks
from here called the hundred east
building
and um you know flirted with each other
didn't really recognize who each other
were saw each other constantly then we
lose track of each other again
and then it is uh late 2009
and she keeps popping up on facebook as
a hey maybe you should a friend request
this person so i do
and then we start talking and within
a month
we have and by talking i mean writing to
each other this is before we even talked
on the phone we fall in love we decide
we're going to get married we start
thinking about plans
we begin talking on the phone and
by summer i have gone up there and you
know we have
met each other face to face again for
the first time in you know decades uh we
go to a conference in toronto together
and start doing all sorts of things then
we begin the long distance
part of our relationship where i would
fly from fayetteville not actually
flying village to drive up to raleigh
and then take a plane from there to jfk
in new york city and then she would
drive down and pick me up and we'd drive
up to the hudson valley and we'd have 48
hours together and then drive back down
and do the whole thing all over again
and after a while that got kind of old
and we're like listen you know we're in
our 40s
screw this long distance stuff you're
not coming down to the south this this
place is messed up i'll go up there by
you
and she had a you know solid gig as a
a assistant dean at the culinary
institute of america she founded the
center for excellence in teaching and
learning you can tell she's a real
go-getter right so um
she had taught at marist college
previously and she said why don't you uh
why don't you adjunct at marist college
you know it's a decent place to go
so i started doing that and i started
teaching intro to philosophy and ethics
for them eventually i taught you know
religion in american culture and you've
you've probably seen those videos from
my early classes
and i did apply for full-time positions
in various places but by then the job
market had really dried up you know
we're still not out of the financial
crisis in 2011 when when i moved up
there
and um you know i i just kept teaching
for for marist eventually i transitioned
actually very early on my second
semester there i start teaching online
for them
because i could take my videos and the
very rich
resources that i provided in my course
management system i begin teaching
online
and you know i start doing all sorts of
other things i get involved in
educational startups obviously i spend a
lot of time shooting youtube videos i
begin building my own business reason i
owe while i'm there originally so that i
can get
i can get tax write-offs for public
speaking and then i start tutoring and
then i get um you know philosophical uh
counseling certification and training
and i begin doing that and i start doing
consulting for businesses and so
you know that went on for quite a while
we were there from 2011
to
2015
and then uh andy's job changed and she
became a consultant rather than an
employee of the culinary institute of
america which meant
that we could now
move back here
to milwaukee
we didn't have to be there in new york
anymore
and we were like yeah let's let's come
home
so you know with our two dogs and kat
and our you know
who knows how many books we had we had
99 bankers boxes worth of books
we prepared for
moving out now i continued teaching
for marist though i kept that because i
was teaching
online
and by that time i was teaching a
different class which i i've actually
replicated in my teachable
study with sadler academy called world
views and values which is sort of like a
an introduction to philosophy class
except it's got some other twists to it
as well
so we reached the final chapter in this
long story the milwaukee years which i'm
still in at present
and when i first got back here i was
still teaching for marist college uh
generally one class per
semester and i was you know
shooting youtube videos i began
podcasting i was working uh on some you
know educational startup stuff and i was
working
uh with with businesses as well starting
to do executive coaching and um you know
other things along those lines ethics
consulting
doing a lot of tutorial work as well so
i you know i had my marist sideline and
then i had my my business stuff over
here
and then the
first
uh main place that i started teaching
for and i believe this was in
2017 in the fall semester was marquette
university
and the way that ended up happening was
i i had done some presentations at
marquette for the philosophy department
and my friend owen over there
he
said hey we've got a visiting assistant
professor position why don't you uh
interview for it and i did and in the
interview i found out that they were
paying essentially peanuts and the
interview basically was over at that
point because i was like uh no they also
had a non-compete clause i'd have to
close down my tutorials not teach for
anyone else and i was like you can't
live on that here in the city with what
you're offering and so that be i was
like that that's that for marquette and
then within like a week they emailed me
and said um
do you think you could teach as an
adjunct for us we've got these ethics
classes
and
the provost is playing around with class
sizes and shrinking them so we now have
a lot more sections that we have to fill
do you think you could help us out and i
was like yeah yeah that'd be great so i
start you know walking to marquette in
the
mornings two days a week and teaching
over there and i've got an office that
i'm sharing with the other adjuncts most
of whom are graduate students and so
it's kind of fun to be like in a
university again you know not not just a
college but a real university
access the library all that kind of
stuff so i'm teaching at marquette and
that was like a pretty reliable
continuing gig and they paid pretty well
for for adjunct teaching
and then i got
solicited by carthage college down in
kenosha wanting to know if i could teach
some philosophy classes for them
particularly business ethics which i was
also teaching at marquette and i was
like yeah i like teaching business
ethics i think it's actually really
important so i begin teaching one class
a semester down there
at carthage as well you notice what's
going on by that time marist becomes
unreliable and it's also messing up our
taxes because it winds up having to pay
you know wisconsin tax and new york tax
so we're like
we're done with marist so now i've got a
couple places i'm teaching i also
apply at milwaukee
area technical college in part because
people are like oh man that's a really
great gig you know if you get in there
pays well you know it's reliable as it
turned out that was true 10 years before
but they'd like a lot of places where
people
took too many liberties then they
clamped down and everything became very
bureaucratic
that was the most dysfunctional place
i've ever taught for there was no
onboarding they have all these crazy
practices and processes the website was
a total mess and unhelpful
people would just like you know
the schedules are just like schedule you
for classes without consulting you it
didn't pay well but i taught there for
for a
a number of semesters
and then i also taught i began teaching
in 2018 for milwaukee
institute of art and design so by this
time i got lots of teaching as a matter
of fact i'm turning down classes
because i'm you know a reliable teacher
and and uh they need the the people to
teach these classes and so i'm teaching
like you know one class here or two
classes here and they're asking me can
you do more for us
and
you know the only the only
one i didn't turn down classes for was
milwaukee institute of art and design
because i really really liked working
there
but you know carthage began kind of
souring on me
same thing with milwaukee area technical
college as a matter of fact they didn't
even begin they started sour
and you know marquette um
it was okay you know and then covet hit
right
so with marquette that meant that
enrollment went down and a lot of things
dried up
i did teach
two sections in
2020 of
business ethics online and that was the
last that i taught for marquette
milwaukee area technical college was
already a mess and cove had made them
even more of a mess
but i kept teaching for them i also
taught prison students for them i should
mention um you know
in the second chance pell program but
then i left that because it was it was
so badly managed as well
um it's too bad because i thought it was
a great program it's just it was poorly
put together and poorly managed
so
you know i started pairing things away
you know marquette went away carthage
wanted me to teach more for them they
they would have had me i did teach two
classes one semester for them online
and during the pandemic they were all
about going online and then as soon as
they thought it was safe they wanted
everything to go away from online and i
was like listen i'm i'm
i'm high risk my wife is even higher
risk i'm not going down to campus to
teach
classes for you all i'm happy to teach
online if you want me to and that
continued all the way to the end of this
this last academic year
and so i started you know marquette went
away carthage
the the writing was on the wall they
also eliminated their philosophy program
and so i was there basically to help
them finish out the majors and i i
decided to quit teaching for milwaukee
area technical college so now i've just
got the one gig as of the end of this
this
spring semester i've only got the one
gig teaching for milwaukee institute of
art and design quite happy with that
because not teaching as many classes as
an adjunct for these other places means
i can concentrate on other things like
my study with sadler academy or light
hall platform classes or listenable
classes or you know being
continuing my client work in tutorials
philosophical counseling ethics
consulting and all these other things as
well so that is the story and this spans
you know more than
20 years starting down in carbondale
illinois finishing up here in milwaukee
a whole bunch of different universities
colleges on the way that i have taught
for
and now you got the whole scoop up to
today things could change in semesters
to come but you know now you know where
i've been what i've done who i've taught
for
why i quit teaching for them why i moved
on to other things you got the full
story
you